over the years a considerable number of
innocent people had unknowingly wandered
into
scp-3008 otherwise known as the infinite
Ikea this extra-dimensional space more
than lived up to its nickname consisting
of an Ikea store with no known limit to
its endless aisles upon Isles of
flat-packed Swedish Furniture but given
the veritable Labyrinth contained beyond
the seemingly ordinary automatic doors
of scp-3008's entrance it was rare that
anyone making their way inside ever made
it back out alive on top of that there
was little the foundation could do to
ensure the safe return of anybody
unlucky enough to find themselves lost
in the infinite Ikea once inside
navigating a way out was made almost
impossible given the scope of the
spatially anomalous store and then of
course there was the staff these tall
humanoid creatures roamed the Isles of
scp-3008 sporting a lack of facial
features disproportionate bodies and
wearing the typical uniform of an
average Ikea worker I think it's
becoming a concern researcher Conley
declared no a problem just how many
people are going missing in scp-3008
what else can we do her colleague
researcher kylan replied shrugging their
shoulders we keep watch over the
entrance and stop anyone from entering
but ours isn't the only entrance calmly
retorted it was true based on evidence
gathered from some survivors that had
made it out of the infinite Ikea the
entrance seemed to exist in multiple
parallel universes say we could figure
out not just a way to navigate through
scp-3008 with better accuracy so people
can make it back out but what if what if
we could use it kylan jumped in
finishing the sentence it could be like
an interdimensional Spaghetti Junction a
hub to access all sorts of other
alternate universes we could send people
through the entrance in our universe and
they could make their way through 3008
and out into another exactly their
fellow researchers smiled one problem
though they said what do we do about
about the staff the inhabitants of the
infinite Ikea were undoubtedly an
obstacle standing in the path of Conley
and kylan's idea The Faceless creatures
were known to be docile during the
daytime cycle within scp-3008 only to
turn violent and attack anyone present
when the light dimmed they're part of
the problem Conley mused but what if
they could be part of the solution the
SCP Foundation hadn't had much chance to
examine a live instance of a staff
member known as
scp-3008-2s up close as such they had a
limited understanding of exactly what
these creatures truly were beyond the
few they had witnessed chasing survivors
out of the entrance were they
intelligent they were apparently able to
speak if only uttering the phrase the
store is now closed please exit the
building did they have the capacity for
independent thought Free Will and
emotionality there was only one way to
find out and so Conley presented her
plan to capture a member of scp-3008's
staff for closer examination not knowing
the bizarre chain of events that would
unfold as a result drawing it out was
the easy part of the plan after all the
foundation knew that
scp-3008-2s were able to react to the
presence of human beings within the
infinite Ikea so Conley proposed sending
in a single member of d-class personnel
with a line of cable attached to them
tethering them to just outside the
entrance of 3008. they were like the
bait on the end of an interdimensional
fishing line and would hopefully catch
the attention of a staff member and lure
them out what do we do once it's Out
Thailand had mused I mean we know so
little about their biology we could use
knockout gas but what if they don't
breathe we could tranquilize it but what
if they don't have blood it had been the
one hitch in Conley's plan although she
had suggested they use pure Force
trapping the staff member like a wild
animal before bringing it back and sure
enough as an instance of
scp-3008-2 came racing out of the
infinite Kia hot on the heels of the
d-class foundation security officers
were able to swoop in and capture the
creature restraining it and bundling it
into a transport back to the site
however upon receiving their captive
staff member kylan and Connolly were
faced with a new problem the creature
seemed to be in its passive state it
didn't seem to be aggressive while away
from scp-3008 kylan had posited their
theory that the staff's attack state was
linked somehow to the day and night
cycles within the infinite Ikea and now
separated from that space the
scp-3008-2 would remain docile but the
larger issue was communicating with it
as patient as commonly tried to be with
the faceless mouthless humanoid it
seemed to be totally unresponsive to
verbal communication any question she or
her colleague kylan asked the staff
member it offered no response dialing it
back to more basic methods of
communication it didn't react when
presented with symbols unfazed by
letters or numbers or even
straightforward forward pictograms no
matter what they tried the staff member
they had captured seemed not unwilling
but unable to respond there's gotta be
something we haven't tried Conley urged
her frustration building after a long
day of trying to get through to the
creature they're capable of speech we
know that from witness reports well
maybe they're a hive mind kylan mused
equally exhausted after their efforts
what if it shares a Consciousness with
the other staff like a drone in an ant
colony hey that's why we should name
this one they added D for drone can we
focus here please researcher calmly
snapped it's almost like we need some
way of enhancing it granting it the
right higher brain function so it has
the ability to speak with us hold up her
colleague replied you said we need a way
to enhance it but what if we refined it
what kylan was insinuating was obvious
albeit a direct violation of the
foundation's own rules
scp-914 otherwise known as the
Clockworks was an anomalous Contraption
of Unknown Origin two booths connected
to the machine when labeled input and
the other output could be used to
disassemble recreate improve or destroy
an object that was placed within scp-914
although there was yet again another
hurdle Conley and kylan would have to
attempt jumping over the foundation had
banned the use of the Clockworks on
biological organisms the pair submitted
a request to their Foundation superiors
for access to 914 and permission to use
it on D kylan hadn't expected their
suggestion to be met with anything short
of a resounding no and while determined
Conley couldn't help but find herself
worrying about the possible highly
likely rejection which made it all the
more surprising that the request was not
only granted but the experiment approved
by the o5 council themselves clearly the
highest operational staff within the
foundation had some Keen interest in
whether the Clockworks could refine an
scp-3008 staff member more likely their
interest was in what benefit the
experiment could potentially lead to if
the foundation possessed a refined staff
member its own agent Within in the
infinite Ikea the possibilities could be
of great advantage to the o5 council
they were less concerned with having an
intermediary using D to communicate with
the other
scp-3008-2s or negotiating the potential
release of the displaced innocent people
lost inside the infinite Ikea if
refining D could mean the council had a
way to safely reach other alternate
universes by traversing through scp-3008
then that bridge between worlds would be
Theirs to control of course kylan and
Connolly were more interested in what
refining D could tell them about the
staff and the nature of scp-3008 did
instances of scp-3008-2 have needs or
wants could they even possess the
capacity to want things were they
fulfilled with their lives as anomalous
Ikea workers and how did they navigate
The Maze of endless Isles imagine it
calmly theorized if Dee can communicate
with them for us we could open up trade
with them the canteen inside scp-3008
endlessly refills with food just picture
what this could mean if we work out a
system of Distributing that resource out
of the Ikea it could change the world
she exclaimed excitedly only one way to
find out right kylan replied they
watched as D their captive staff member
was nudged into the input Booth of
scp-914 Conley gave the research
assistants a signal to activate the
Clockworks hoping that refining D would
allow them to be capable of speech and
free thought however either through
miscommunication or a Secret order from
above one of the assistants had
incorrectly calibrated scp-914 it was
meant to be set to fine which would
improve whatever was placed in the
machine but instead the dial had been
turned to very fine which improved the
target item to an Ever greater extent
often granting it anomalous properties
before anyone even noticed the change
the gears and Gyros of scp-914 clicked
and word into life making a raucous
noise of moving mechanical Parts
destroyed in the input Booth only to be
Recon instituted into something
altogether new in the output 1 opposite
de-emerged from scp-914 after the
process was complete its clothing seemed
to have experienced the most noticeable
change instead of being the usual yellow
shirt and blue trousers Ikea uniform
worn by the rest of the staff D was now
sporting the same clothes but the colors
seemed to be shifting almost like the
natural camouflage of a chameleon they
were still faceless their body still
incorrectly proportioned compared with a
human and for the most part D seemed
unchanged but before kylan and Connolly
could move in to take a closer look
before they were even able to check if D
could speak the staff member vanished in
the blink of an eye an instant state of
panic erupted throughout the foundation
facility alarms were howling over a
containment Bridge security teams were
dashing through every wing of the site
to track down D swept up in the chaos
that quickly ensued Conley and kylan
received another message from the
highest point up the chain of command
find that staff member and bring it in
alive or there would be hell to pay from
the o5 council but somehow there was no
sign of D anywhere in the facility they
had gone scans of the building revealed
that all members of personnel all
anomalies and other registered forms of
life were all accounted for it was only
when kylan ran through the mess hall
that they realized where there were fine
test subject had gone to hey turn that
up they yelled to a security officer who
had been quietly enjoying his lunch
break standing on a chair he reached up
and raised the volume of a TV that was
mounted to the wall overlooking the mess
hall the screen was depicting a live
news report the anchor on the ground
standing outside the entrance to an
ordinary IKEA store I'm standing outside
the very store where this bizarre turn
of events have taken place the anchor
explained police received numerous calls
regarding sightings of an unknown figure
said to be scaring Shoppers however they
only responded when this clip went viral
on social media the report cut to cell
phone footage of none other than D
inside the store their unit form had
shifted into its typical Ikea colors
almost like it had adapted to suit the
place it had somehow transported itself
to from the mess hall kylan watched the
footage in a mix of shock and confusion
naturally the reaction from bystanders
was one of fright that the individual's
rather odd faceless appearance some took
to Twitter posting images calling it
some form of viral marketing hoax others
claimed it was a publicity stunt by Ikea
to boost sales although in a statement
the company denies these accusations
however it was then reported that the
supposed creature began I'm reading this
right aren't I the anchor paused for a
moment started helping customers by
directing them to store departments
recommending different Ikea furniture
and perhaps strangests of all did all
this via oh come on really telepathic
communication Conley had appeared in the
mess hall just in time to witness the
news Dee had gotten free and immediately
sought out the nearest IKEA to work
there the next few hours contained a
maddening slew of new information Nation
bombarding the foundation as researchers
kylan and Connolly scrambled to figure
out some way of recapturing D it didn't
seem that the scp-3008-2 instance was a
danger to civilians in fact most reports
stated that they were rather friendly
any customers that interacted with the
creature described its new communication
patterns in five star reviews they
apparently felt compelled to start
posting online I've never experienced
anything like it one wrote D offered the
most delightful customer service I have
ever received that's why they must have
gotten their name d for delightful it's
not like d speaks in your head another
review explained it's more like they
just give you their thoughts being
directly in there I said where can I
find the bathrooms and fittings
department and instantly Dee had given
me the directions it was as if I'd
always known having an anomaly like d
out in the open raced all sorts of
problems for the foundation for one they
would not have to only scrub every
mention of the staff member from the
internet but also track down anyone that
had interacted with d to an administer
amnestics but that was far from the
worst of it the researchers had been so
caught up in coordinating a recapture
effort that they didn't realize how
rapid and extremely widespread the D
reviews were getting they were being
left on customer satisfaction boards for
stores in different states within
minutes of each other it took only 15
minutes for a review that mentioned Dee
to be left in a store that wasn't even
an Ikea outlet but a convenience store
thank you Dee for such lovely and Speedy
service at the cashier's desk never had
such a nice conversation and interaction
with anyone else in the store before the
review read the news that D could
seemingly be in multiple places at once
appearing in different stores was
confirmed when Conley and kylan saw
photos posted online of the creature
wearing what looked like a number of
alternate uniforms it seemed that Dee's
clothing once exclusively just an Ikea
shirt and pants switched to match the
uniform of whichever store they started
to work in and the more they worked the
more places they seemed to appear
perhaps the most shocking devil
development came almost 50 minutes after
d had been refined and had disappeared
once again turning their attention to
the news researcher kylan watched as the
manager of a huge Supermarket franchise
store appeared giving an interview live
talking about how the altered scp-3008
staff had caused him to change his
entire business practice listen D is
great our customers love D I hear the
company's shareholders love him too one
thing's clear we all love D you said
jovially but something was unnerving
about his gleeful smile so to show them
our appreciation I am hereby announcing
that effective immediately all my retail
staff are no longer required to come
into work he does it all so there's no
need for anyone else they're friendly or
quieter they work faster and they're
more efficient than any employee on my
payroll that's right folks these here to
stay naturally this move Sparks serious
controversy with the stores disgruntled
now former employees finding themselves
out of work a number of them took to
social media in an outcry of
dissatisfaction this is unfair I've
worked every weekend through college at
that store and now I'm fired just like
that thanks a lot D one of them
protested it's all corporate Ploy
another wrote the rumor is that the only
reason they're laying us all off so
quick is because D doesn't technically
count as a human employee so they don't
have to pay them they're working for
free so the store manager and the
company that owns the store can keep
every penny of the profits the Justified
outrage seemed to go willfully ignored
as another store announced it would be
adopting the same policy firing all its
staff and letting Dee take over their
duties more and more photos started
pouring in right before Conley and
kylan's eyes of multiple refined
scp-3008-2 instances working behind
cashier's desks refilling shelves with
products assisting customers these seem
to be acting out of instinct like they
couldn't help being staff it was their
purpose the horde of anomalous staff
members ended up swarming over the
country's retail industry simultaneously
like the drones of an ant colony kylan
what the hell have we done done Connolly
asked staring in disbelief at the TV
screen we've done the unthinkable they
answered equally horrified we created a
monster we took D out of scp-3008 and
made them into the most powerful retail
worker on the planet within hours every
retail outlet of every different
description not just Ikea had reported
the firing of their entire staff and
every business that did was now raking
in record profits droves of Shoppers
flocked to stores all enjoying Dee's
customer service so much that they were
taking any excuse they could to rush out
and buying well anything as stock
supplies started to deplete more and
more instances of the altered
scp-3008-2 appeared taking over the
supply chain and distributing products
to the various stores they were working
at refilling the shelves in record time
naturally the o5 council was Furious
researchers kylan and Connolly had hoped
to present them with a refined scp-3008
staff member that could allow them to
better understand the infinite Ikea now
the council's ulterior motive of having
access to an interdimensional Bridge of
other universes had been dashed as if
that wasn't bad enough and the added
hassle of D rapidly becoming a worldwide
sensation the economy was destabilizing
thanks to the retail companies firing
their staff and hoarding massive amounts
of profit from all their stores and
thanks to having decompulsively working
there refining an scp-3008 staff member
looked like it was about to collapse the
stock market and plunge the whole world
into chaos
um our bad researcher kylan Shrugged
unsure what to say after they and
Connolly had just been brought before
the shadowy 05 Council to be reprimanded
there was only one thing for it D had to
be taken out of the picture and quickly
the more they worked the more they
seemed to be able to multiply and spread
then with a greater number of D
instances within a store the faster and
more efficient they were able to work so
in retaliation the o5 council
begrudgingly activated mobile task for
alpha 1 better known by their code name
red right hand this task force reported
directly to the council there were some
of the foundation's most loyal
operatives and it was far from their
first assassination mission well they
had assumed it would be an assassination
dispatching the red right hand to a
nearby Ikea where D had first
transported themselves to After exiting
914. of course the place was overrun
with d duplicates but even after
clearing out the entire store and
administering amnestics to any customers
that witnessed it there were still
plenty more of D out there the council
quickly realized that they'd have to
send MTF Alpha 1 to every branch of
every Outlet in the country
systematically taking out every
duplicate of D in a lengthy cleanup
operation until they were no more it
seemed the foundation's Personnel had
their work cut out for them hopefully
they'd be entitled to a raise and some
paid time off after all of this was over
now go check out how to actually beat
scp-3008 the infinite Ikea and I
survived 100 days in scp-3008 here's
what happened for more of the world's
most huge anomaly